Speaker 1: Here's an interesting follow up
on a story from earlier this year.
Back in January, we covered this guy named
Christopher Dickey, who was promoting the
drinking of urine in order to treat or prevent
COVID.
And we talked about it at the time, and I
explained to you then that a lot of this covered
quack stuff.
It's a recycling of old ideas that have been
going around for a long time.
Urine has been promoted in the past for treating
cancer, even though the Cancer Society says
there's no evidence at all for therapeutic
use of urine.
They've talked about using urine to irrigate
the sinuses, almost like a pee neti pot for
brushing teeth, applying it directly to the
skin as a skin treatment of some kind.
And the origins or the oranges of this urine
therapy thing is the idea that certain tumor
proteins are present in the urine of cancer
patients.
And the idea is if you introduce urine into
the digestive tract by drinking it, the erroneous
belief is your body will make antibodies against
the tumor proteins and it'll destroy the cancer.
That's like one example now there's no evidence
of that whatsoever.
It's true that urine can contain tumor antigens.
There's no evidence that drinking it, massaging
with it, bathing with it, cooking with it
or any other urine application is going to
stimulate antibody production in any way,
fight cancer or treat any symptom or disease.
So that was the idea before from Christopher
Qi was the drinking of urine.
He's now moved on to promoting injecting urine.
Here is a clip of him at least claiming that
he's injecting himself with aged urine.
You know how sometimes people will age stakes.
This is aged urine.
Speaker 4: I'm doing it for muscular.
I have your eye dying, but I'm just going
to sterilize it with my own urine, right?
And and what not to talk about the stem cells,
right?
Speaker 1: All right.
So and as this is going on, you see him take
out a syringe.
Speaker 4: So pretty much every every type
of stem cell is available in your urine.
So stem cells are the base pure DNA cells
that will start replicating.
Yeah, additional cells for regeneration and
repair.
I mean, everybody's hearing about regeneration
People are flying to Thailand to get stem
cell injections done over there.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So the idea there is that Christopher
Qi has injected himself with urine, and some
people wrote to me saying, David, he clearly
isn't really injecting himself.
I don't think it matters because if people
believe it, it's dangerous.
And this is all from the same school of thought
that sometimes includes homeopathy.
Sometimes it includes, you know, some of these
other.
I'm not going to rap too much, either.
This is what it is.
OK, now this is extraordinarily dangerous
if you, you know, Christopher Qi said he's
injecting the urine intramuscularly.
If you inject urine into a vein, it can get
very bad, very quickly.
There's actually a study called lethal sepsis
and multiorgan failure after accidental injection
of urine in a drug addict, and the story is
about a 33 year old drug addict that injected
urine because he kept it in the fridge in
case he needed it for a drug screening.
And then he thought it was methadone and injected
it, and it went into a vein and was confused
and shivering and had all sorts of different
symptoms.
Sepsis, it was crazy.
OK, so this is all extraordinarily dangerous,
and they just don't seem to be stopping now.
I genuinely wonder, like, are they really
making money with this?
I don't know.
The guy who's interviewing Christopher Key
here is Dr. Edward Group, and he runs some
kind of natural healing thing.
And does he make money promoting urine therapy?
I just don't know.
I don't I don't know exactly like what the
what the money piece is now.
As I've said before, there is one possible
legitimate life-saving use of urine, and it
is as follows If you are completely dehydrated,
you're without water, you're on the verge
of dying.
There is a short period during which drinking
your own urine could extend your life just
enough to be rescued or to get to water right.
Urine is 95 percent water, and it's believed
that drinking your own urine might allow you
to survive an extra day or two.
It is strictly speaking, safe.
It replenishes some lost water.
But the problem is the other five percent
of urine that's not water is not something
you want a lot of in your body, right?
You're taking the stuff that your kidneys
have filtered.
Out, and you're putting it back in and putting
it back into your kidneys, and this can cause
really bad symptoms and long, long term problems.
But if there's anything that in the urine
therapy world, we would say is sort of legit.
It would be you might extend a deadly situation
with no water by a day or two.
And that's basically it.
Absolutely horrifying stuff.